For
years fans of the Star Wars franchise have
expressed frustration with the fact that Chewbacca
didn’t get a medal at the close of Star
Wars: A New Hope despite playing a pivotal
role in the destruction of the Death Star.
Since then, George Lucas constantly meddled
with his films, but stopped short of giving
a CGI medal to Chewbacca and instead decided
that Greedo apparently had the worst aim in
the galaxy…
But why didn’t Chewbacca get a medal in
the first place?
To begin with, there’s currently no canonical
explanation for why the lovable Kashyyyk wasn’t
rewarded for his bravery when his co-pilot
was.
This is because after Disney gained ownership
of the Star Wars franchise, they decided to
delete from canon the entire Expanded Universe
so that you don’t get to know ahead of time
what’s going to happen in the upcoming films
and their writers aren’t bound to storylines
in the numerous comics, video games and books
released by Lucasfilm over the years.
(It also no doubt helped that this way they
can make a whole lot more money by rebooting
the entire thing with many new books and other
media based on the upcoming films coming soon
to a store near you ;-)). While the old Expanded
Universe certainly could use a little house
cleaning (with Lucas having been notoriously
lax at policing inconsistencies in it), this
is a little unfortunate as particularly Heir
to the Empire, Dark Force Rising, and The
Last Command (the first of which set five
years after Return of the Jedi) are awesome
and would have been amazing to see on the
big screen in some form or another.
Ah well…
In any event, as a
result of all this, the current official canon
of Star Wars is limited to that established
by the core six films (despite the issues
with I-III), The Clone Wars TV show and any
games, movies or books that are going to be
released by Disney in the future.
While Disney has acknowledged that its writers
are free to take inspiration from the Expanded
Universe, they’re also free to ignore it
to come up with their own ideas, so long as
it doesn’t contradict the canon Disney establishes
from here on out.
Meaning, Chewbacca never got a medal, Boba
Fett never escaped the Sarlaac pit and Darth
Vader’s glove never went on a planet hopping
adventure after Luke cut off his hand.
But since we never pass up an opportunity
to delve into the Star Wars Universe, we may
as well thumb our noses at Disney’s decree
and dig deeper into the saga of Chewie’s
lack of a medal.
For this, we must go back to the beginning…
A long time ago in a galaxy far, far too full
of terrycloth jumpsuits, George Lucas gave
an interview recorded just a few weeks after
the release of A New Hope; when asked why
Chewbacca got stiffed on the medal front,
Lucas explained that the Wookiee people “do
not care for medals” and as a result, Chewbacca
simply didn’t want it.
This is strange, because according to the
film’s novelization which was released six
months before the film and was supposedly
written by George Lucas, Chewbacca did get
a medal during the award ceremony.
As it turns out, the book was actually written
by a ghostwriter called Alan Dean Foster,
who based the majority of the novel on Lucas’
original screenplay where Chewbacca was awarded
a medal for his part in destroying the Death
Star, meaning it was initially Lucas’ intention
for him to get one: [Draft from May of 1974]
Queen Leia, in all her grandeur, sits on the
magnificent throne of Aquilae.
Starkiller and the general stand to her right.
Several old advisors stand to her left.
Han presents Chewbacca and a delegation of
Wookees with a treaty, gifts, and a medal
of honor.
They bow and exit.
Han moves to one side of the crowded court.
Exactly why Lucas decided to make this change
during his many revisions of the script isn’t
clear, because he eventually went back on
his explanation that Wookiees don’t place
value in tangible rewards in a later interview
with the Official Star Wars Fan Club, instead
claiming that Chewbacca did get a medal in
a small ceremony after the one seen in the
film.
Lucas explained that because Princess Leia
was so much shorter than Chewbacca, who is
canonically stated to be 7 feet 6 inches tall
(3 inches taller than Peter Mayhew, the actor
who physically portrays him), she couldn’t
place the medal around the Wookiee’s neck.
Chewie_medalThis explanation was expanded
upon in the 1980 comic, The Day after the
Death Star!
In it, Chewbacca is given a medal by Princess
Leia in a small private ceremony, with Leia
having to stand on a table so that she can
reach him comfortably.
(Although, why he couldn’t just bend down
is anybody’s guess.)
The comic also alludes to Lucas’ earlier
assertion that Wookiees don’t place value
in material rewards by showing that Chewbacca
initially refuses the medal, only changing
his mind at the behest of Han Solo, thus explaining
why he was awarded it the day afterward.
But even if you reject such works that are
no longer part of canon, Chewbacca was (kind
of) awarded a medal some two decades after
the original film during the 1997 MTV movie
awards.
At this award ceremony, he won a “Lifetime
Achievement Award” which was intentionally
styled to look exactly like a Medal of Bravery
from the film and was presented to him by
none other than Princess Leia (aka Carrie
Fisher).
While not exactly canon, the award was largely
seen as a tongue in cheek way of addressing
one of the major fan complaints about the
original trilogy and was supported by Lucasfilm
who provided Mayhew with a copy of his costume
to wear on stage.
Upon receiving the award, Chewbacca addressed
the crowd and uttered a few shorts words of
appreciation before being given a rousing
round of applause.
In the end, while he may have been slighted
in A New Hope, as Chewbacca himself (Peter
Mayhew) noted, Chewie did get the last word
in the film
Speaking of film endings that had a glaring
mistake, in the original TV version of Rudolph
the Red-Nosed Reindeer, Rudolph, Hermey, and
Yukon Cornelius promise to help the toys on
the Island of Misfit Toys.
However, once Rudolph and company leave the
island, they never actually bother to help
the toys.
This resulted in numerous complaints that
Rudolph broke his promise, so a new scene
was added to the end of a subsequent version
of the film where Rudolph leads Santa to the
island to collect the toys.
According to Mayhew, during the filming of
the Endor scenes, he wasn’t allowed to walk
around the forest in costume without guards
because the crew were concerned that he’d
be shot by a hunter, perhaps mistaking him
for Bigfoot.
Ironically, in one questionable Extended Universe
comic called, Into the Great Unknown, Chewbacca
and Han Solo crash into a forest on Earth.
While Solo is ultimately killed by natives,
Chewbacca survives and spends 126 years roaming
the forest where he becomes mistaken for Bigfoot
in later years.